For shows as dark and suspenseful as NCIS,
it's hard to imagine one scene's subject matter
seeming harder to watch than the rest.
So what event could be so heart wrenching
that it outshines an entire season?
Keep watching to discover the one scene NCIS
Season 9 took too far!
As sad as it is to see familiar faces leave,
one universal truth has emerged: NCIS likes
to craft dramatic exits for its characters.
As time has gone on, audiences have gotten
used to living with the worry that something
terrible could happen to their favorite investigator
at any moment.
Packed with ups, downs, major plot twists,
and plenty of NCIS's classic brand of drama,
Season 9 is no exception to this gruesome
storytelling style.
In it, we see everything from Tony DiNozzo,
played by Michael Weatherly, getting shot,
to Cote de Pablo's character Ziva David receiving
a marriage proposal.
In crime dramas like NCIS, there are plenty
of scenes that may be difficult for some audiences
to watch, especially while experiencing the
rest of the emotional turmoil included in
Season 9.
However, there is one particular scene involving
a major character that is almost too shocking
to talk about.
In NCIS Season 9 Episode 24, Till Death Do
Us Part, it's not a grisly crime scene or
awkward moment that leaves viewers reeling.
Instead, audiences get a taste of this show's
trademark heartbreak when, at the end of this
action-packed season finale, fan-favorite
medical examiner Donald "Ducky" Mallard, played
by David McCallum, has a heart attack.
The shocking event is one of many packed into
the hour-long season finale, and its placement
in the latter half of the episode only adds
to the tension.
Till Death Do Us Part sees Gibbs and his team
pull out all the stops as they continue to
investigate a series of deadly explosions.
Gibbs recruits Dr. Samantha Ryan, portrayed
by guest star Jamie Lee Curtis, to help identify
the cause.
Soon, a man named Harper Dearing, played by
Richard Schiff, becomes the focus of the NCIS
team's investigation.
In the final act, Dearing's last bomb goes
off right outside NCIS headquarters.
This scene would be dramatic enough by itself,
but it's only made worse by the fact that
Gibbs, McGee, Ziva, DiNozzo, and Abby are
all trapped inside by the damage.
In the episode's final scene, Ducky is seen
walking along the beach.
As he takes in the view, he receives a call,
presumably about the fatal bombing.
Ducky demands that nobody touches the bodies
of the deceased, then pauses as a heart attack
strikes.
"It's imperative that no one touches the deceased
until I…Until I re-"
The last image of the Season 9 finale shows
Ducky collapsed on the beach as the tide rolls
in.
The heart attack seems to be the result of
overwhelming stress from the shocking phone
call, and audiences are left to wonder about
Ducky's fate, and the fates of all his trapped
team members.
The NCIS Season 9 finale ends so dramatically,
the fact that it has stuck in the minds of
fans almost a decade after it aired should
come as no great surprise.
In June 2021, when a Reddit user posed the
question, "Any episodes of NCIS that made
you cry?"
fans had no trouble coming up with plenty
of iconic moments that hit a little too close
to home.
Even still, Ducky's heart attack made many
viewers' lists despite the 18 seasons of drama
they had to pick from when the thread was
posted.
A redditor included this scene in their top
three, along with the deaths of Gibbs' father
and Palmer's wife.
The commenter went on to clarify,
"There are more that hug at the heart, but
these three made me cry."
Ducky is a vital character in the series,
whose charm and random educational banter
has fans fully invested in his well-being.
So watching him have a heart attack in the
ninth season finale of NCIS was a scene that
was a bit too much for some audience members
to handle.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.